words she thought to never have to say
but today holly dance confirmed her
child's death it's with my deepest
sympathy
i'm sadness
to tell you all the archie passed at 12
15 today
okay to say i'm the proudest mum in the
world such a beautiful little boy
and he full ryan's from the very end
and i'm so proud to be his mum
he um
he was taken off of all medication at 10
o'clock and his entire stats remained
completely stable for
two hours until they remove the
ventilation
and he went completely blue
there is absolutely nothing dignified
about
watching
a family member or a child
suffocate
twelve-year-old archie battersby was
found unconscious at home in south end
on sea on april 7th he had a ligature
around his neck and his mother believes
he'd been taking part in a dangerous
online game
since then bart's health nhs trusts have
fought his family doctors treating him
here at the royal london hospital had
argued that it was in his best interest
for life support treatment to end his
family disagreed
in a statement today the trust said
our thoughts and heartfelt condolences
remain with arch's family at this
difficult time the medical staff
provided high quality care with
extraordinary compassion over several
months in often trying and distressing
circumstances
this tragic case not only affected the
family and his carers
but touched the hearts of many across
the country
outside the hospital today tributes
archie will never see
but his life and the way he died will no
doubt leave questions about medical
ethics british law its international
obligations and the dangers of online
challenges
for holly just a life without archie
here's what she told us yesterday just
walking opening my front door
and seeing where
i was giving archie cpr on the floor so
the door opens
i don't know how i'm going to cope with
that and then walking up the stairs and
seeing him obviously where i found him
i don't know how i'm gonna cope i'll be
lying if i said i did
a decision for the courts an
immeasurable grief for a family
sadia chowdhury sky news at the royal
london hospital in london